roumanie le comité de salut national
annonce sa victoire mais les combats se
poursuivent entre l'armée les ministres
de chaouch et secoue la france les états
unis seraient d'accord pour que les
troupes du pacte de varsovie
interviennent en roumanie
berlin réunifié pour noël il n'y a plus
de visas de part et d'autre du mur
répression du trafic de l'ivoire le
gouvernement français fait détruire tout
mais saisies effectuées par les douanes
françaises disparition de max favalelli
mort à l'âge de 84 ans journaliste
cruciverbiste il était surtout connu des
français comme l'arbite les chiffres et
des lettres sur antenne 2 madame
monsieur bonsoir
au soir du troisième jour de la révolte
du peuple roumain contre l'ex dictateur
ceausescu la télévision annoncer la
victoire mais les combats se poursuivent
encore entre la population et l'armée
ralliée au gouvernement de salut
national d'un côté et les forces
spéciales qui dépendaient directement du
dictateur ces hommes n'ont plus rien à
espérer aucune retraite possible ils ont
même tout à craindre d'une population
terrorisée pendant vingt-quatre années
de dictature c'est pourquoi ils
continuent à se battre à bucarest et
dans plusieurs villes roumaines
retranchés dans des immeubles ou
embusqués sur des toits ils font régner
la peur et continue de tuer empêchant la
population de savourer une libération
qui de toute façon ne sera plus remise
en question jean-marc il use et rick
perry demandait rien à personne
c'était un gamin de 10 ans ils ont tué
non assassinés pas toujours
un témoignage parmi une dizaine d'autres
sur les actes de violence gratuite des
partisans de ceausescu
les partisans aux abois mais qui aura
entendu hier soir la douleur d'un
adolescent à sibiu bastion de l'un des
fils du dictateur déchu sibiu tout à la
joie de sa première victoire sur les
forces de la sécurité
presque au même moment à l'autre bout du
pays à chis 400 km au nord-ouest de
bucarest vivait ses derniers combats au
bord de la victoire
il faur individus aussi à l'aéroport de
bucarest enjeu stratégique majeur ou les
faire tant d'hommes sont déjà énormes
premières images de reddition mais
l'aéroport est fermé
les forces de la securitate et n'ont
peut-être pas dit leur dernier mot
à bucarest même les symboles d'un
pouvoir tommy tombent l'un après l'autre
ici le siège du comité central du parti
communiste roumain seul détenteur du
pouvoir pendant 42 ans
au troisième jour des combats la
population toujours aux côtés de l'armée
pour répondre au feu fournois et
terriblement précis des miliciens sur
entraîner des risques
lui à bucarest europe on meurt et on
crie l'armée avec nous et la méfiance
est partout ici l'arrestation d'un civil
regardez il est du ministère de
l'intérieur
oui mais c'était seulement un type qui
travaillait à la comptine méfiance
guerre du renseignement
ici un commissariat improvisé pour le
tri des suspects puis inspecteur chef
non il ment à la télévision porte-parole
clés du nouveau pouvoir les émetteurs
sont encore intactes un commando a été
neutralisée de juste à ce matin
le studio de l'état joutes souhaité
transformer en infirmerie et on a même
trouvé ici le coeur de se détendre un
peu en musique
ce que l'on appelle aujourd'hui les
terroristes n'ont pas entendu l'appel au
cessez le feu lancé cet après-midi par
le comité de salut national ces
miliciens qui formaient l'armé
personnelle pourrait-on dire de
ceausescu se bat non seulement pour
tenter de sauver leur peau mais ils
veulent encore semer la terreur nous
avons tous encore en mémoire le charnier
de timisoara la ville d'où est partie la
révolte roumaine il continue en s'en
prenant à tout ce qui bouge tirent sur
la foule mitraille dans les immeubles et
même sur les hôpitaux
le reportage qui va suivre le prouve on
touche là au comble de l'horreur hervé
brusini au coeur de bucarest
la monstruosité tant bien que mal ses
miliciens protège cet hôpital de secours
car dehors on leur tire dessus
on est même venu massacrait jusque dans
ce bâtiment venez regarder dit le
médecin
là
lui c'est un terroriste il hommes en
blanc certainement la securitate et la
garde prétorienne de chaouchi secouent
certains d'entre eux disent les témoins
étaient drogués prêts à assassiner tout
ce qui bouge
il y a là une centaine de corps où se
mêlent tueur et victimes des combats de
rue
certains ont été tuées au sein même de
l'hôpital
ça fait plus de vingt ans fut médecin
légiste même à l'époque du tremblement
de terre j'ai pas vu ça j'ai jamais vu
une telle boucherie chine où vas tu en
as tu es on a fusillé même ici à
l'hôpital
ils ont tiré de ce côté et de ce côté
aussi l'hôpital
je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer une telle
chose j'aurais jamais cru des êtres
humains soient capables d'une telle
chose
jamais ce soir c'est noël dit le
journaliste
y'a pas longtemps je savais encore un
poème qui disait je te prie toi bon et
juste seigneur sauve mon pays et mon
peuple pour la roumanie libre à bucarest
les combats entre armée forces de
sécurité ont fait plus de 5000 morts
aujourd'hui les médecins roumains manque
de tout plasma sans calment anesthésique
seringue
à l'extérieur un homme des forces
patriotiques montent la garde devant des
cercueils
devant l'horreur nous l'ont tout à
l'heure en fin de journal les
différentes adresses où vous pouvez
adresser vos dons pour la roumanie à la
fin du journal tout à l'heure j'ai en
ligne maintenant l'ambassadeur de france
à bucarest monsieur lebreton monsieur
lebreton vous m'entendez monsieur
l'ambassadeur vous êtes en ligne avec
nous en direct de bucarest c'est ce que
vous entendez monsieur lebreton
monsieur l'ambassadeur je crois que nous
avons quelques problèmes de liaison oui
on l'entendait la liaison a été coupée
pour l'instant nous allons rappeler dans
quelques instants l'ambassadeur de
france à bucarest et nous ferons avec
lui le point de la situation ce soir
pour savoir notamment où on est l'état
des combats ce soir dans la capitale
roumaine
un premier bilan fait état en tout cas
de 5000 victimes dans les combats de ces
dernières 48 heures pour bucarest
seulement s'il est vrai que les
terroristes comme on les appelle
aujourd'hui n'ont plus aucune chance de
renverser le cours de l'histoire
il continue donc de faire régner la peur
on vient de le voir à l'instant et en
voici la confirmation avec le reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux françoise joly
et roger mode pour accéder à la
télévision qui est le quartier général
est le centre nerveux de la révolution
il n'avait que quelques centaines de
mètres à parcourir mais dans quelles
conditions
bucarest il y à quelques heures à peine
nous sommes quelques mètres bâtiment un
bâtiment dans lequel il est extrêmement
difficile de pénétrer extrêmement
difficile d'approché parce que toujours
sous le feu nourri de la police et de la
glisse alors en
une accalmie qui peut être viendra où
dans les bouches de métro à l'abri qu'on
attend le moment du passage
venez dans notre entrée de ce métro
l'armée a déjà pris position depuis plus
de 24 heures au bord de l'épuisement
premiers instants de répit
le but est là bas au bout de l'avenue le
bâtiment de la télévision et puis tout à
coup sans vraiment comprendre pourquoi
c'est le moment il faut sortir et courir
rester groupés dépêchez-vous de chaque
bâtiment de cette avenue peuvent partir
des rafales d'armes automatiques des
francs tireurs
ici chaque fenêtre est un péril chaque
passant un suspect
arrivé sur la place de la télévision
moment de tous les dangers
identification est ici une question de
survie
il ya quelques heures encore des tirs
d'armes automatiques partait de cette
fenêtre
vu que quelques mètres il en se disant
que même à l'intérieur des bâtiments de
la télé d'où on doit absolument envoyer
ces images des miliciens sont infiltrés
ce n'étaient que 100 m dans les rues de
bucarest 100 m 10 avec le coeur à 160 et
depuis l'envoi de ce reportage nous
avons eu de nouveau notre envoyé spécial
françoise joly au téléphone de la
télévision justement voici son
témoignage françois joly tellement que
les combats ont duré que dans le reste
des caresses la vie continue à dérouler
normalement je serai investi par les
terroristes rebelles
donc s'il sait que tout déplacement dans
ce bâtiment est très très déçu ce que
l'on voit c'est l'armée présente des
parachutistes
enfin ce en revanche les rebelles les
terroristes comme on les appelle ils
sont possédant plusieurs bâtiments
autour de la télévision il a fait de la
population organisée en armes n'arrive
pas à les déloger semble déterminé à se
battre ici jusqu'au dernier homme pour
30 ce bâtiment nous avons rencontré tout
à l'heure très jeune soldat puis a pris
spontanément le commandement des unités
de civils armés elles vont protéger
certaines rues proches de la télévision
mais nous avons vu quelques bcc la
population en est c'est en en brigade
les accus à l'aide de d'hier nous avons
traversée nous dans toute la région sud
ouest de la roumanie pour enfin revenir
ici intéresse et partout dans toutes les
idées que nous avons traversée sur la
route
nous avons vu ces rassemblements de fans
et de gentils brandissaient des drapeaux
sous lequel il avait enlevé le cycle du
parti communiste et c'est très heureux
de voir étaler le v de la victoire de
demandant mais comment dépasser les
frontières pendant couvert on leur a
prises dans certains cas nous leur
apprenons petroci reserré ouverte et
donc ils vont très très très
enthousiaste et très hâte à mobiliser
après les combats il faut nous
intéresser maintenant au sort de la
famille chaouche escou cet après-midi la
fille de nicolas elena ceausescu zoé a
été arrêté non loin de budapest toute la
famille est donc arrêtez maintenant le
fils nick ou la fille zoé que vous voyez
sur ces images si je ne me trompe pas
l'image que je découvre en même temps
que vous oui la voici donc dans cette
anorak zoé ceausescu
arrêtez donc cet après-midi confirmation
pas ces images que vous voyez en ce
moment même quant au couple ceausescu
que sont ils devenus où sont-ils
exactement la télévision roumaine a
officiellement annoncé leur arrestation
hier soir c'était hier soir mais ils
n'ont pas toujours été pour leur part
filmer ou photographier la dernière
version en date qu'il faut toujours
prendre au conditionnel donc affirment
qu'ils sont incarcérés sur une base
militaire au terme d'une fuite commencé
à partir d'un bunker de bucarest où il
avait d'abord trouvé refuge thierry km
le dernier discours jeudi après-midi le
commencement de la fin du conducteur le
début de la fuite
conspué par la foule le génie des
carpates se réfugie dans le palais
présidentiel et vendredi matin jugeant
la situation désespérée il décide de
s'échapper
d'abord vers l'immeuble du comité
central qui jouxte le palais un seul
moyen suivre un des nombreux souterrain
secret qui truffent les bâtiments sur le
toit un hélicoptère latent qui décollent
vers une destination inconnue
à ce moment tout le monde pense que le
dictateur va rejoindre un avion pour
s'envoler vers la chine
en fait à l'extérieur de la ville une
voiture dacia rouge l'attend direction
tir gaulliste et à 75 km de la capitale
là depuis une base militaire secrète il
tente de réorganiser sa terrible
securitate
mais voilà vendredi soir ou samedi matin
selon les sources
il sera arrêté avec une grande partie de
sa famille dès vendredi une dépêche
datée de 16h30 précisé que si vous chez
ce coup venait d'être aperçu un
hélicoptère puis dans une dacia rouge
immatriculée 02 04 nouvelle démentie
quelques minutes après en fait une rue
des insurgés pour empêcher une tentative
de libération par la securitate
voici la version la plus récente de la
fuite
dictateur mais tant que la télévision
roumaine ne le montrera pas capturer le
doute subsistera oui dans les jours qui
viennent on apprendra sans doute
beaucoup sur la famille chaouche escusa
fortune ses privilèges connu à
l'étranger mais que les roumains
commence à peine à découvrir en
regardant leurs nouvelles télévisions
laurent bouvier réception avec des
tables richement garnis de produits
introuvables dans les magasins de
bucarest robe du soir dans des tissus
que les ménagères roumaine ne peuvent
même pas imaginer petit à petit les
roumains découvre le luxe dans lequel
vivait le couple ceausescu et ses
proches alors que la population était
rationné à 100 g de viande par mois et à
6h de chauffage par jour grâce à la
télévision est un album de photos
trouvées dans le palais présidentiel
les habitants de bucarest revoil nagore
un ancien parc de promenade que le
dictateur s'était attribué il ya une
quinzaine d'années et qui l'avait
transformé en lieu de vacances pour lui
et sa famille
port privé bateau château terrain de
sport tout y était construit pour le
bien-être de l'ex numéro un roumain jeu
d'échecs et tire au fusil électronique
pour celui qui se faisait appeler le
stratège des stratèges rencontres avec
des scientifiques pour celles qui se
prenait pour un savant de renommée
mondiale
les roumains découvre ces images du
passé
le commentaire ironique et amer du
présentateur de la télévision roumaine
souligne que les nouvelles conditions de
vie d'elena et nicolas ceausescu seront
maintenant beaucoup moins luxueuses bien
jeux en ligne maintenant de nouveau donc
l'ambassadeur de france à bucarest
monsieur lebreton m'entendais bien est
ce que vous pouvez
à l'heure qu'il est nous faire un point
de la situation est ce que les combats
ce soir se poursuivent avec la même
intensité ou bien ont-ils baissé
d'intensité continue je dirais que cet
après midi ils ont baissé d'intensité
tout au moins dans la zone où se trouve
l'ambassade
mais naturellement je ne peux pas parler
pour l'ensemble de la liste des combats
ont eu lieu dans le quotidien
et cette forme au nord de pau et pose
problème le comité de salut national
annoncé tout à l'heure sa victoire
laissant à penser que ces combats se
continuaient mais qu'il ne s'agissait
que de poches de résistance de miliciens
qui ont le dos au mur et ce que vous qui
connaissez parfaitement la situation
à bucarest en roumanie nous pensaient
que ces combats peuvent durer un certain
temps de penser que l'armée ralliées
peuvent venir à bout de ces de ces
miliciens
oui je pense je pense en effet que vous
voulez le comité ducati nationale que
keira de la partie mais
comme qui sont réitérés le ceausescu
sont encore assez qu'est l'orgue hésité
parce que beaucoup de mal et sont entrés
dansez maintenant
l'art mais est elle tente hier radio ne
peux pas encore le dire un certain
nombre 2 permettent de penser que je
reste encore des postes prestigieux et
et des soldats très violent résister
alors nous allons passer dans un instant
une interview de monsieur dumas la
ministre baird étrangères français qui
n'exclut pas et de demander à l'union
soviétique d'intervenir par
l'intermédiaire du pacte de varsovie si
les événements se prolongeaient ce que
vous avez été saisis vous d'une demande
d'intervention quelconque de la france
sur le plan international par lé conseil
de salut national
non le conseil de salut national a
remercié ce matin lorsque j'ai repris
contact avec lui de l'aide que nous
apportons dans le domaine humanitaire et
en particulier on est extrêmement
sensible à la venue de monsieur bernard
kouchner et des sages il accompagne
on a dû quant à demander une aide
militaire et trois tables soit
l'attention des autorités
vous mais je le dois le demander à l'eau
oui bien merci monsieur l'ambassadeur je
vous quitte un instant parce que
maintenant nous avons en ligne et à
l'image l'une de nos envoyés spéciaux
patricia cause patricia vous m'entendez
de bucarest bien alors déjà une première
question patricia où êtes vous là
écoutez la radio la télévision les chars
entoure ce bâtiment qui est assiégée par
les francs tireurs pour l'instant c'est
assez calme car depuis l'application
c'est assez arrangé mais les esprits
sont extrêmement nerveux
les légions soupçonne tout le monde se
demande s'il n'ya pas d'écran tireur
parmi les passants parmi ceux ci veulent
rencontrer à la télévision et par
exemple nous nous sommes restés à la fin
de la télévision pendant une heure et
ont vérifié nos identités est en fait en
était extrêmement exposées bien à
l'instant même nous avions françoise
joly au téléphone patricia ainsi que
l'ambassadeur de france donc il nous
faisait état de combats toute la journée
vous étiez dans bucarest vous avez vu
ces combats vous êtes presque je crois
bloquer aussi pendant plusieurs moments
quelle est la nature des combats est ce
qu on a l'impression que c'est c'est la
fin où ça perdure ça risque de durer un
moment encore écouter pour l'instant il
ya encore donc des francs tireurs qui
ciel mais perd sa points névralgiques la
capitale par exemple la place de la
république où justement autour de la
télévision en ce moment mais les tirs
ont baissé d'intensité
petit à petit les francs tireurs se sont
arrêtés les uns après les autres et puis
dans une mission
mais l'armée face à eux est extrêmement
peu expérimentée elle
lance à l'assaut dans les immeubles il
n'y a pas de combats au corps à corps et
il faudra rester des pages de résultats
certainement encore quelques jours
chacun semble rester un petit peu sur
ses positions effectivement que vous
êtes de dire et on al'impression vous
allez nous le confirme et patricia que
la la population est très exposé on a
parlé de 5000 victimes on voit à chaque
coin de rue des gens qui se trouvent
derrière les militaires devant les
militaires c'est votre impression aussi
c'est votre sentiment
oui c'est extrêmement curieux la
population malgré les ordres des
diversions continue à se rendre
justement sur les points les plus
névralgiques et on a l'impression que
c'est cru dont elle vient de prendre
possession
elle ne veut surtout pas la lâcher elle
ne veut surtout pas la lâcher ses fins
il ya une autre explication c'est que
une partie de la population a plus ou
moins finalement fait l'abhorré avec le
régime six ou sept fous et aujourd'hui
en faisant quelques secondes leur vie
elle fera chaises on a eu cette
impression
on a l'impression de revivre d'une
certaine façon ce qui s'est passé en
france à la fin de la dernière guerre
mondiale
ces hommes de la milice et hommes de la
securitate qui sont arrêtés dans les
rues est ce que vous avez ce sentiment
de suspicion entre j'allais dire les
roumains eux mêmes tout le monde
s'observe un peu oui il est tout le
monde ça serve il ya des barrages
absolument partout à chaque coin de rue
soul on se sent tout le monde mais cela
fasse dans une espèce de taxe carbone
enfants et on annonce entre extrême
excitation mais le pouvoir et à la
population et à force de discuter tout
arrangement refasse une affaire très
attendu dernière question pour l'instant
vous essayez de rester en ligne avec
nous patricia là en ce moment autour de
la télévision quel point névralgique
accalmie tout semble relativement calme
où il ya vous entendez des des tirs et
des combats autour de vous non en fait
je vous disais tout à l'heure la tension
baisse
la télévision est maintenant extrêmement
défendent ya défendu par l'armée mais
les trois tireurs font toujours officier
il est très difficile de les déloger
bien merci patricia on se retrouve donc
dans quelques instants si vous avez
d'autres informations
j'aurai maintenant de venir sur le plan
politique la question qui se pose est
donc de savoir que l'armée ralliée aux
comités de salut national
ont-ils besoin oui ou non d'une aide
internationale et sous quelle forme
le président du rpr monsieur jacques
chirac estimait cet après midi que
monsieur mitterrand aurait dû s'exprimer
depuis 48 heures sur cette affaire en
envoyant par exemple du matériel
militaire en demandant aux soviétiques
d'intervenir dans ce pays qui je vous le
rappelle appartient au pays au pacte de
varsovie pardon on le sait moscou n'a
pas l'intention d'intervenir pour
l'instant autrement que matériellement
cette critique de jacques chirac
monsieur dumas le ministre des affaires
étrangères français ya répondu d'une
certaine façon à l'avance en indiquant
que la france n'a pas attendu
aujourd'hui pour entreprendre des
démarches internationales monsieur dumas
interrogé par jacques merli de la france
depuis le début de l'insurrection est
aux côtés du peuple roumain sur toutes
les formes imaginables dead de façon à
permettre à ce peuple qui s'est soulevé
de recouvrer sa liberté et d'abattre ce
qui reste de dictature
ces deux corps dans ce contexte qu'il
faut voir les contacts que j'ai eus des
heurts avec les autorités soviétiques
qui viennent du has de nous faire savoir
aujourd'hui même qu'elle était d'accord
pour entamer avec une coordination de
toutes nos z
s'il y avait un appel venant de bucarest
n'appelle un comité national aux grandes
puissances occidentales vous pensez que
celles ci sont prêtes à répondre à cet
appel les premières consultations
auxquelles je me suis livrée me donne à
penser que la communauté internationale
à l'est comme à l'ouest répondrait à un
appel de s'étendre bien j'étais en train
de converser au téléphone avec bucarest
je crois jouer qu'on met sur l'image on
croit la reconnaître françoise joly
notre envoyé spécial bruno gex là nos
envoyés spéciaux et bernard kouchner
le secrétaire d'état à la solidarité
nationale vous m'entendez
tous les trois
nous entendons effectivement en direct
ici au rez-de-chaussée de l'ambassade de
france à bucarest à mes côtés bernard
kouchner
bruno geste qui a accompagné la mission
de bernard kouchner
donc cette émission qui a démarré hier
nous sommes posés à varna donc à
l'aéroport de bulgarie puis les
autorités bulgares nous ont mis à notre
disposition des camions du matériel la
suite nous les remercions et surtout il
faut dire que nous sommes arrivés
aujourd'hui à bucarest que l'accueil a
été formidable et que c'était à la fois
une joie un peuple meurtri met en joie
que l'arrivée des autocars français et
des camions a été quelque chose
d'inoubliable que tout le monde s'est
levé dans la rue on a l'impression que
si quelqu'un d'étranger pas c'est un
français maintenant et il faut
évidemment faire le bilan parce que
c'est très difficile de savoir quels
sont les besoins nos chirurgiens et nos
anesthésistes travaille déjà à l'hôpital
des urgences
il faut dire que d'autres médecins
étaient là médecins du monde d'hier
médecins sans frontières aujourd'hui et
claude malhuret et que cette cette
présence française c'est tout à fait
formidable mais les besoins sont
immenses
ils sont immenses d'abord parce que la
médecine n'était pas un stade peut-être
suffisant pour affronter cet afflux de
blessés
et puis parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
travaillé et que tout le monde est
fatigué il faut voir ses enfants dans
les rues qui prennent possession de la
rue pour la première fois et les
médecins qui sont épuisés après des
nuits et des jours de travail
même si je crois et je l'espère le
nombre des blessés n'est pas aussi grand
qu'on l'imaginait je le souhaite
beaucoup
il va y avoir beaucoup de travail la
mission est à pied d'oeuvre d'ores et
déjà alors quelle est cette mission
précisément très précisément c'est une
mission humanitaire avec la sécurité
civile avec la croix rouge avec le
personnel du ministère de la santé
ça veut dire aider nos collègues d'abord
les relevés et en ce moment les médecins
et les chirurgiens français travaillent
leur apporter du matériel dont ils
mentent être à leurs côtés surtout c'est
être là c'est une présence indispensable
c'est plus encore symbolique que
pratique et ça va être très pratique
alors oui on peut le dire quand même on
l'a vu dans le regard des enfants et
dans leurs gardes et des blessés à
l'hôpital
une telle sauvagerie une telle violence
inoubliable quelque chose de
complètement monde
puis s'est déroulée ici dont il faudra
tenir compte pour écrire l'histoire de
la fin de ce siècle et de ce siècle qui
s'ouvre sur la liberté
mais on a le sentiment quand même ce
soir que c'est le premier noël de la
liberté pour les roumains alors je crois
que les roumains banques essentiellement
de médicaments nous avons été moins
jean-françois hoffman le cameraman et
hervé gasparini le preneur de son et est
voir dans un hôpital pour enfants
ce manque de médicaments liberté liberté
habache house fout qu'il soit jugé pour
le sang versé nous sommes d'azur joue
poste frontière avec la bulgarie la
mission humanitaire du gouvernement
français avec à sa tête bernard kouchner
vient de pénétrer en territoire roumain
sous les acclamations de jeunes
manifestants georgiou ou la veille 15
personnes civiles et militaires ont été
tués par les agents de la terrible
secteur it à 60 km plus loin l'arrivée à
bucarest
une foule en liesse l'aide française est
avant tout musical dansé vu 70 hommes ça
me voir ou cityville
il apporte des médicaments si fun car
c'est ce qui manque le plus aux roumains
exemple dans cet hôpital pour enfants
solidement gardés par l'armée régulière
ici on redoute l'action isolée de francs
tireurs dans ce service de réanimation
angel à 6 ans elle vient de perdre un
sans doute une des plus jeunes victimes
de la surrection la paix par mba dans le
vent c'est réparable
terroristes qui continuent à l'épouvanté
la population suivre les rues quillan
quelques coins de l'italie
c'est un jour des vendeurs qui r lité
contre les terroristes qui a reçu deux
balles
les infirmières travaillent sans relâche
depuis quatre jours avec les moyens du
bord
ici on manque de matériel et de
médicaments
en ce moment c'est sans résistance
l'anesthésié d'analgésie parce qu'il ya
une grande quantité des malades qui
souffrent physiquement psychiquement qui
sont choqués à cause de ces tragiques
événements des événements qui auront
marqué la jeune génération qui n'a
jamais rien connu d'autre que ce régime
avant on pouvait rien faire si je
l'avais glienicke je ne pouvais pas le
dire aux eaux à l'hôpital chacun peut
être un espion
yes c'est pas mauvais je pense que nous
pouvons faire des choses merveilleuses
ici pour les roumains ce sera le premier
noël en liberté un sapin déposé à
l'entrée de l'hôpital
à ses pieds des bougies à la mémoire des
victimes du régime de ceausescu
voilà ce qu'on peux donc vous dire ici
ce soir en direct de bus karen moi bien
sûr les combats continuaient autour de
la télévision
ici à l'ambassade de france nous avons
aussi essuyé quelques tirs
et bien je vous donne rendez vous dans
nos prochaines éditions de mardi
télématin à 13h effet bien sûr 20h 23h
bien bien entendu françoise comme vous
nous l'indiqué à l'instant nos
installations de directs sont maintenant
sur place vous avez vu fonctionner ce
soir dans notre journal de 20h à deux
reprises et bien entendu tout au long de
cette nuit des journées qui viennent
nous interviendrons maintenant tout
simplement gelé dire
en direct de bucarest quand nous le
voudrons et quand les événements leur
rendrons obligatoires je résume très
très rapidement les autres titres de
l'actualité il y avait un panama le
général noriega reste introuvable
l'armée américaine tente d'éviter le
pillage de la capitale panama city
washington a envoyé des renforts et
s'aperçoit washington que cette
exposition n'a pas été parfaitement
réussie
loin de là et puis il y avait berlin la
7e heureusement la joie quelque part
dans le monde aujourd'hui à berlin
premier noël réunifiée dans les faits
depuis 28 ans d'autant que l'on a
supprimé aujourd'hui dimanche donc les
visas pour les allemands de l'ouest et
de l'est de part et d'autre du mur
et puis une nouvelle plus triste celle
là la disparition à l'âge de 84 ans de
max favalelli le journaliste français
cruciverbiste bien connu de tous les
amateurs de mots croisés connu également
de tous les français de tous les
téléspectateurs français comme arbitre
dans l'émission des chiffres et des
lettres sur antenne 2 pendant une
vingtaine d'années
voilà je vous donne un autre résultat
pratique celui là le tiercé qui se
courait cet après-midi rapidement les
chiffres pour ceux qui ont joué le 1 le
18 le 19
et puis pour ce qui concerne le quarté +
le set en plus pour gagner un peu plus
de 22 mille francs jours et maintenant
vous donner avant de nous quitter en
prenant quelques minutes tout de même
les adresses et les comptes chèque
postaux des associations qui vont vous
permettre d'aider les roumains qui en
ont bien besoin la formule est un peu
banale vous en êtes aperçu tout au long
de ce journal alors prenez le temps de
les noter équilibre ça c'est la première
association médecins du monde médecins
sans frontières et puis je crois une
autre liste ou bien celle ci est une
liste unique non aide médicale
internationale ccp 4,45 44,5 paris
fondation de france ccp 3 169 g paris la
croix-rouge roumanie ccp 600 00 il y est
bien entendu il y à bien d'autres
associations qui en ce moment et c'est
d'aider la route m la roumanie notamment
les municipalités ou les mairies
d'arrondissement pour les grandes villes
là je vous conseille
de vous rendre dans ces mairies et puis
de voir comment vous pouvez si vous le
désirez bien entendu aider les roumains
dans leur combat d'aujourd'hui
alors vous avez vu fonctionner nos
installations de direct je voudrais vous
dire que il y aura demain matin à partir
de 6h30 un journal continue en direct de
bucarest avec ici dans nos studios
invité de françois ponchelet à partir de
6h30 donc monseigneur virgile georgiou
patriarche de l'église roumaine une des
figures de la résistance au dictateur
ceausescu ça c'est à partir de demain
matin 6h30 bien entendu et puis tout au
long de la journée bien entendu dans nos
différentes éditions et puis dans les
flash toutes les heures sur notre chaîne
et bien entendu si ce soir il se passait
quelque chose nous interviendrons au
courant dans le courant de la soirée we
bien voilà
pas d'autres informations pour l'instant
on va se quitter je vous souhaite tout
de même un joyeux noël ce soir et puis
les prévisions météo de josé blanc la
pierre dans un instant joyeux noël et
bonne année pour la semaine qui vient
bonsoir